democrats getting cold hard cash to keep
their loved ones safe while leaving your
neighborhoods at the mercy of dangerous
criminals despite a big push from
president biden to refund police
departments house democrats are delaying
a plan to do just that at the same time
every member of congress is set to get
ten thousand dollars to put in security
systems in their homes
including 150 a month just to maintain
them but it gets better as democrats try
to run away from the defund movement one
top leader says it's a lie to call them
out over it listen
the notion that any of our frontline
members
or members of the house democratic
caucus support defunding the police is
just part of the big lie that extreme
mega republicans continue to tell about
everything oh boy rosanna i'm sure you
know we have
minutes and minutes of tape of the squad
i believe they considered them to be
front line members the house democratic
caucus saying to fund the police until
like a couple of months ago you know so
many people have been saying defund the
police until you really look into how
they live for example in new york city
our public advocate jahmani williams was
running for governor we find out and he
was leading protests all over new york
city defund the police which he said
really wasn't about defunding the police
it was about appropriating it somewhere
else anyway we find out that jumani
lives on a military base
fort hamilton it's a gorgeous space i
didn't realize like 15 of the military
base civilians can apply to live there
it's very difficult you won't find it on
zillow
but anyway he lives there beautiful
townhouse
uh sweeping views of the verrazano
uh burger king is there 14 haircuts
that's it 14 haircuts my sister but wait
a second
24-hour military security that's what it
is defund the police geraldo now you're
seeing them people that you know
didn't want anybody to be protected in
our in our cities crime ridden cities
and now they get 10 grand 10 grand
that's a lot of moolah geraldo put put
aside the
private security
that's chump change in the big picture i
think that the real problem is that the
house has a bill that will
fund jurisdictions to hire cops
invest in mental health and implement
violence intervention they can't pass it
why can't they pass it because the squad
feels they need more protections against
police brutality they need more
limitations on the cops they got to
ensure that the police are uh are
even-handed when they do it so it's it's
bs really that they are refunding the
cops they are defunding by inaction and
i i really criticize them for data talks
bs walks if they really want to fund the
police let them fund the police and not
uh continue this uh this nonsense he
said dana talks bs walks that's what i
heard dana
that too
i i do i want to comment on that at that
point but i also want to say that when
hakeem jeffries is up there and he's
talking about that
anyone who says that democrats don't
want to fund the police that's the big
lie these are the worst communicators in
the history of the world they had the
big lie
branded as
a about election fraud
and that that was and you know what
that's whatever but now
they've muddled that completely and now
everything is the big lie so you've
already lost again on that one
congratulations that was not very smart
also i'm just so mad about this because
the abigail spamberger moderate democrat
from virginia she was the one who was on
the conference call after the election
saying guys we have a serious problem we
have we have to do something so nancy
pelosi says abigail please go forward
try to get this bill done she gets it
all the way to the one-yard line and
then these outside groups like the
leadership conference and the civil
leadership conference on civil and human
rights they massively supported defund
the police they picked up their pens and
their phones and they killed it and now
good luck to the democrats when they're
trying to do all this stuff from the
minority because somebody like abigail
spamberger she's in a very close race
nancy pelosi gave her a chance to try to
fix it so she could go home and say she
did something and now the squad killed
it i think we should drink every time
dennis says abigail spammer
you mentioned her name a lot it's very
cute oh really yes yes yeah i just get
hungry
it's a hell of a name i definitely want
to try spam
as a burger and you
do you have to remember that time when
they were crying for to fund the police
it was at a very vulnerable moment in
our country it was it was an indulgence
by leaders of the mob right uh it was a
really ugly thing to hear your
politicians say you know what we're
willing to destroy civil society to
placate people on the street peop the
twitterverse the at the loudest
activists this was not about making
society better it was about a bunch of
people virtue signaling
the worst thing a leader can do is
virtue signal that's all the left does
now is virtue signal so i understand why
why they are running from this now
because it's it's kind of disgusting
it's really scummy what happened but it
does boil down to the initial fact in
that first tease we as americans are
paying for the security which they
refuse to take care of ours they are
supposed to be servants of the people
it's not supposed to be the reverse and
it shows why they got into the business
of politics so they could be exempt from
the punishment and the laws that they
enact on us think about it globally they
don't suffer crime because they're
protected with security they don't wear
masks when we were all wearing masks
they don't fly commercial if they can
have they can they can run red lights
look at lori leadfoot uh and you know if
you're real if you've got a really big
liberal name you can let a woman die in
a lake and still be in politics so
that's the whole key is if you're in
power you can get away with everything
that we can and we got to pay for it i
still say take the criminals when they
get released put an ankle bracelet on
them drop them off within like a a like
a radius a short radius of
these leftist homes and and the beepers
go off whenever they leave that
neighborhood they have to stay in the
neighborhood where these idiots make
these rules and maybe they'll live maybe
they'll learn the consequences of their
own realities i like that idea do you
have just dumping criminals yes and
politicians
find alvin bragg's street don't put in
front of his house but then just drop
the people that have been released in
new york in his to do it with gasco oh
oh oh oh what
how is stop signing emotional like a
tiny fraction of what they did to
kavanaugh and the other supreme court
justices
good point
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now